salut après un an et demi de vidéos de
spectacles et d'écriture de livres j'ai
décidé de faire une pause cet été pour
me reposer oui mais aussi pour vous
préparer une renaissance de la chaîne en
septembre vous est demandé sur twitter
si vous vouliez quelques facteurs rapide
et divertissant en attendant alors
pendant ces 60 jours de pause je vous
laisse une vidéo rapide et sans
prétention tous les jours pairs à 11
heures on se retrouve à la rentrée et
tout de suite ça lui je suis persuadé
que vous connaissez les darwin awards
qui récompense un petit peu glauque pour
récompenser les pires morts vous
connaissez aussi peut-être les gérard
qui récompense les pires animateur télé
ou les plus mauvaise émission
eh bien il ya aussi la même chose pour
le prix nobel s'appelle le pij et nobel
parce que ça fait ignobel et depuis 1991
tous les ans il décerne une dizaine de
prix un petit peu atypique et qui
paraissent pas toujours utiles 2014
ignobel de physique à des chercheurs
japonais qui ont consacré la recherche a
calculé le frottement entre une peau de
banane une chaussure entre une peau de
banane et le sol et enfin le graal
ultime le frottement d'une personne qui
marche sur une peau de banane qui elle
même posé sur le sol
la science avance 2016 ignobel de
médecine pour des allemands qui au terme
de leurs recherches se sont rendu compte
qu'on pouvait transformer une
démangeaison du côté droit au côté
gauche par exemple ça me gratte là je
peux le transférer la en se regardant
dans un miroir et en grattant de l'autre
côté qui nous gratte
est ce que c'est bien clair cette
histoire si ça me gratte à droite je
regarde dans un miroir et je me gratte
du côté gauche
voilà 2015 ignobel de chimie à des
chercheurs australiens grâce à eux on a
une méthode pour des cuire un oeuf
c'était 1,9 cuit on peut le décrire et
sa baisse et bien je suppose 2012
ignobel de la dynamique des fluides des
chercheurs aux états unis ont consacré
leurs recherches leur temps et leur
budget pour étudier ce qui se passe au
niveau du ballottement des liquides
quand une personne marche avec une tasse
de café dans la main que vous pouvez
retrouver plein des comme ça sur le net
ça change un petit peu justement des
darwin et je pense que c'est pas encore
très connue donc j'espère que ça vous
aura fait marrer si c'est le cas
n'oubliez pas de laïcs et vous pouvez
vous abonner comme d'habitude une vidéo
tous les deux jours cet été jusqu'au 30
août donc rendez-vous après demain après
demain
ciao